So we're continuing sort of our tour through
the absolutely outrageous things that Donald
Trump said during his rally, like press briefings
at his own golf club over the weekend.
And yes, this is reality as far as we know.
And one of the things he said and that he's
been saying more and more is he's going to
protect people with preexisting conditions.
Now, you might hear that and say, wait a I
remember this debate from 10 years ago.
Obamacare protects people with preexisting
conditions.
And you would be right.
One of the big accomplishments of Obamacare
that is very popular with the entire country.
It's not just Democrats that, like the preexisting
condition provision, is that Obamacare made
it the law that health insurance companies
can't reject you because you have a preexisting
condition.
They can't reject coverage of that preexisting
This is so popular that now Donald Trump is
just claiming he's going to do it by executive
order, except, of course, it's already the
law.
Check this out.
It's really beyond belief.
So over the next two weeks, I'll be pursuing
a major executive order requiring health insurance
companies to cover all preexisting conditions
for all customers.
That's a big thing.
I've always been very strongly in favor.
We have to cover preexisting conditions.
So we will be pursuing a major executive order
requiring health insurance companies to cover
all preexisting conditions for all of its
customers.
This has never been done before, but it's
time that people of our country are properly
represented and properly taken care of.
Now, you're not mishearing that Trump is promising
to do something that is already the law thanks
to Obamacare.
If you can believe this, Trump saying this
was reported as breaking news by some media
outlets.
It was breaking news 10 years ago when the
Affordable Care Act was first signed into
law.
Meanwhile, Trump's own administration is suing
to try to dismantle the Affordable Care Act,
which is what protects people with preexisting
conditions.
That we've never seen anything like this before.
We really haven't.
And part of why is because of who's in the
White House.
Part of why is because of who supports the
sky.
We've never seen anything like this before.
Trump is saying, I will sign an executive
order to enforce the law from 2010, which
I've been trying to repeal since I became
president of the United States.
The provision Trump wants to make law with
an executive order is preexisting.
If you can imagine that we've had it for a
decade now, I actually do not think that this
is Trump being stupid.
This was a speech that was on paper in front
of him.
Right.
Trump didn't just come up with this out of
thin air.
He doesn't write the speeches.
Obviously, this is a calculation that he can
do the same thing with preexisting conditions
that he's been doing with veterans choice
there.
I think it's been a dozen times or so that
Donald Trump has said when asked about his
accomplishments from his first term.
He says Veterans Choice.
Now, Veterans Choice is an Obama accomplishment
from 2014.
And Trump has taken credit for it.
A dozen, maybe two dozen times similarly here.
Coverage of preexisting conditions is very
popular with Americans, as it should be.
And Donald Trump is going to try to take credit
for it to get himself reelected.
He's throwing everything at the wall to see
what sticks and what might help him in November.
Plain and simple.
Nothing more.
Nothing less.
And we know he will try to take credit for
a coronavirus vaccine, which is likely to
enter emergency use sometime around the election.
No thanks to Donald Trump.
We know Trump will try to take credit for
any treatment, including ones that were tested
mostly in other countries.
If they end up being effective to deal with
Corona virus and he might get away with it.
That's the understanding.
We can't realize Trump will try to take credit
for this stuff and laugh and say, ha, nobody's
going to fall for that now.
63 million people voted for him in 2016.
Three million people already fell for it.
There are clearly millions of Americans who
will believe that Trump cured Corona virus
or found a vaccine or protected preexisting
conditions because they believe anything he
says.
And that's what the next three months have
to be all about, which is to overwhelm the
vote to such a degree that none of these bamboozle
things and lies actually help Donald Trump
to get reelected or they'll help him, but
they won't actually get him over
the hump.